let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
so i was i was away uh when this big
bombshell dropped
big big bombshell the biggest
bombshelliest
bombshell of them all but fortunately
you know
i could still weigh in because just last
night there was another there was
another bombshell related to this
another development
we'll talk about that in a second i'm
referring of course to the melania tapes
melania trump the first lady
used to be friends with a vile wretch of
a woman
named stephanie winston wolkoff and i
only call her that because i call her a
vile wretch of a woman because she was
secretly recording for a period of time
secretly recording her friend and you
know i would say that secretly recording
someone who
you claim to be your friend so that you
can give the tapes to the media later
i think that qualifies you for the vile
wretch camp personally
um and uh but let's so so the
the the the first tape that came out
this was last week
you probably heard the first one but
let's play it again anyway this was the
um
tape that was released a few days ago
media is making a big deal of it but
here's what was said
a [ __ ] about christmas stuff and
decoration but i need to do it right
yeah but
imagine a hundred percent you have no
choice and
okay and then i do it and i say that i'm
working on christmas uh planning for the
christmas
and they said oh what about the children
that they were separated
give me a break
where they were saying anything when
obama did that i know
i cannot go i i was trying
to get the kid reunited with the mom
i i didn't have a chance needs to go
through the process and through the law
but here's my thing hear what you just
said but instead of that
if if you just your messaging
you you were so loved you would not do
the story
we put it out they would not do the
story
until you would not believe it they
would not
do the story because no they are not
they would not do the story because they
are they are
they are against us because they are
liberal media
yeah if i go to fox they will do the
story i don't want to go to fox
so that tape is supposed to prove
something i don't know exactly
i don't know what they thought it proves
what it proves to me
is that melania is much nicer and more
buttoned up um than a lot of people are
in private including me
okay she was being recorded by a trusted
confidant
and that's the worst thing they caught
her saying was that
you know it has to be the worst there
are a lot of tapes out there but they're
going to lead with their
their the biggest one the worst one
they're gonna lead with that
and that's it i can just tell you this
if a trusted confidant was recording me
secretly for weeks on end you would hear
a lot worse than that a lot worse
i can tell you and that's the irony is
that both
trump and his wife have been secretly
recorded by people they trusted
for trump it was michael uh cohen and
somehow
they weren't caught saying anything
horrible
they're actually it would seem they are
less offensive in their private lives
than the average american that was the
surprising thing from
for me with with the trump tapes
especially is that he's actually
he's more outrageous in public than he
is in private
um so what do you hear in that tape
melania complains about the media
rightfully so
um you know because they refuse to cover
the good things that she and her husband
are doing she's complaining about that
she complains about christmas
decorations
the left tried to make that into a oh
she's waging a war on christmas oh
please
who doesn't complain about christmas
complaining about christmas decorations
is a time-honored american tradition
it's as american as as blue jeans and
drive-throughs it's it's the most
american thing in the world
we that's this is what we do we put up
the christmas decorations and we
complain about them
we complain about them while we're
putting them up
anyone who ever grew up you know
watching their dad hang the christmas
lights outside
you can attest to this all the colorful
language that came out of your dad's
mouth as he was trying to hang the
christmas lights
um and so that was the first thing uh
the worst thing she did was she
complained about
uh christmas decorations then last night
another tape was dropped
this one is even at this one's probably
even more
shockingly unshocking than the first
this is what she said listen
uh annie labove shot the porn
hooker and she will be one of the issues
september or october
what do you mean she who she shot the
porn hooker
stormy yeah and that's it she refers to
stormy daniels as a porn hooker
which she is it's a pretty decent
uh description
and that's it there's no there's really
not much else to it than that
i i gotta i'm i am really really
surprised i i just sort of assume
can you imagine okay what if there were
michelle tapes what if michelle obama
had been secretly recorded by her most
trusted
ally and friend in secret for you know
for weeks
what kind of stuff do you think we'd
hear i'm thinking
probably worse stuff than i don't want
to hang the christmas decorations
um all right here's another story that i
missed last week that i have to circle
back
and uh and talk about reading from the
website discern
headline navy seals changes creed to be
gender neutral removes brotherhood
other gendered language it says uh us
navy seals
and the navy special warfare combatant
craft crewmen have
recently changed their ethos and creed
to be gender-neutral
removing gendered words like brotherhood
according to naval special warfare
spokesman
lieutenant commander matthew stroup in
an emailed statement to american
military news one of the changes to the
seal
ethos is an altered sentence that says
common citizens with uncommon desire to
succeed
instead of the original a common man
with uncommon desire to succeed
uh then he goes on to explain says um
naval special warfare continues to
deliberately develop a culture of
tactical and ethical excellence that
reflects the nation we represent
and that draws upon the talents of the
all-volunteer force who meet the
standards of qualification as a seal
blah blah blah etc and so forth uh now
we should also mention that trump has
come out against this and said that he
wants to reverse it thankfully
whether it's reversed or not though the
fact that the navy seals are even
considering
doing gender-neutral language is lunacy
and let's start with the simple fact
that no woman has ever been a navy seal
no woman in history has ever been able
to endure the physical demands to become
a navy seal it's never happened
and not for lack of trying so at a
minimum
maybe we should wait until a woman
actually manages to become a seal before
we
consider changing the language for this
hypothetical woman it doesn't even exist
also spokesman stroup said said you know
this is part of the
the ethical excellence no it's exactly
the opposite this is capitulation
it is surrender to the pc culture it is
precisely the opposite
of what you want to see from the navy
seals this is not ethical
excellence oh yeah we're caving we're
caving to the demands of um
screeching purple-haired feminists
because it's it's ethically excellent
it's the ethically excellent thing to do
no you know you got to be able to
withstand an assault from the feminists
because these are the people that are
out the navy seals are out in
god forsaken corners of the of the of
the world going against the baddest of
bad guys
so they should be able to withstand
you know an attack from gender studies
majors
and they can of course the actual navy
seals can but they're not the ones
making these decisions this is coming
from bureaucrats
who continue to do everything they can
to ruin everything that's good about
america
all right number three here's something
extremely disturbing the parents of one
of the
the kids who were killed in in the
parkland shooting in 2018
they've teamed up with an activist group
and come up with an
ai version of their dead son
so that he the dead son the the ai
could deliver an anti-gun message like i
said extremely disturbing
here it is i am patricia oliver
and this is my husband manuel two years
ago our beautiful son joaquin was shot
and killed at parkland every day i think
about him
and what his last moments must have been
like
meanwhile every day nearly hundred more
families
lose someone they love to go on violence
every single day we keep telling people
it doesn't have to be like this they
don't listen
so we found a way to bring back someone
that no one
will ignore it's very hard for me to
look at this
so please please listen to what
our son has to say
[Music]
yo it's me it's guac
i've been gone for two years and
nothing's changed bro
people are still getting killed by guns
what is that everyone knows it but they
don't do anything
i'm tired of waiting for someone to fix
it
the election in november is the first
one i could have voted in
but i'll never get to choose the kind of
world i wanted to live in
so you've got to replace my vote okay i
can't watch any more of that that
that uh i cannot fathom
using my child like that
i can't fathom using my child for
political messages
you know even as my child is alive
uh much less when they've died
tragically
in doing this it's
i'm not even gonna continue i think uh
i'll just i'll just leave it at that
number four
the u.n um actually u.n women that's the
group because
women need their own u.n it seems u.n is
the united nations
women apparently aren't part of nations
so they need their own u.n
um and that's where u.n women comes in
and it's good that you and women exist
because we need them for stuff like this
here's the tweet from un women
uh it says you can avoid being a
mansplainer by asking yourself these
questions
did she indicate any desire to hear this
information
is it possible that she knows more about
this topic than i do
did i read the room before starting to
speak
and then it offers a helpful explanation
of mansplaining or definition rather
definition is the practice of a man
explaining something to a woman
in a way that shows he thinks he knows
and understands more than she does
like i said this is good mansplaining is
certainly one of the great threats
facing the world you know we used to
think it was terrorism nuclear holocaust
global conflict war disease famine no
it's none of that uh it's mansplaining
a man might explain something to a woman
and the woman might get her feelings
hurt
by the explanation and that's the
problem that is the real nuclear
holocaust if you will
that we that we all face now of course
you read these questions and you think
okay has any woman ever in her life
asked herself any of those questions
before speaking
especially did he indicate any desire to
hear this information
i mean you tell me ladies have you ever
asked yourself that question before
saying something to a man has any wife
especially
ever in the history of marriage asked
herself that question before saying
something to her husband
if wives did 95 of marital communication
would disappear overnight
so this is another example of feminists
blaming men for something that women
are certainly the primary culprits of
feminists do this a lot i've talked
about it before um but the whole idea
that
men are the ones talking too much
that's just what is this opposite day it
it's it's it's mind-boggling
i might as well claim that women
are the main ones in a marriage guilty
of clogging up the drains
from their beard clippings you know that
that's primarily a woman
problem i might it's as absurd and
granted you know there might be some
women
with luscious beards who clog up drains
i'm not judging i mean good for you
if you are a woman with a beard like
that but statistically this is probably
more of a man problem
just as mansplaining ironically is
actually more of a woman problem than it
is a man thing
okay number five finally um there was a
rally over the weekend i think this was
in miami
pro-trump rally and uh anyway here's
what happened watch
[Applause]
[Music]
yes uh they were barking like dogs just
so you're not confused
those were if you're listening on the
audio podcast
that's so you had two leftist women
um and they were wearing their masks you
know they're being very
so very socially conscious in that way
wearing the masks and they were
at this protest they were i guess
counter protesting by
barking in the faces of the trump
supporters
and that was what you saw there that was
basically twitter in real life people
say that twitter isn't real life no
that's that's it that's twitter right
there that's what twitter is
but really for me the most perplexing
thing about this when i watch
a video like this is that there were two
of them you know
because what that tells me
you got two women barking what that
tells me is that either
this was spontaneous and one of them
started barking
and the other one saw it and went wow
that's a good idea i think i'll do the
same
or they talked about it ahead of time
and planned out like they planned this
to go there and bark like dogs
they had a conference and one of them
said hey
you know what we should do we should go
to this trump protest
and uh no listen to this listen bark
like dogs
yeah bark in their faces that's what we
should do and the other one said
i like it i'm in let's do it either way
whatever
however that happened however that
developed whatever the genesis was of
that
um it's it fascinates me i'm absolutely
fascinated
by it and you know there are many other
words i could use besides fascinated but
we'll go with fascinated
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt walsh show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content